[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Today we are so excited
to have Dr. Francesca Gino here
joining us.
She is a behavioral scientist
and the Tandon Family Professor
of Business Administration at
HBS, Harvard Business School.
And she will be talking
to us about some
of her recent
research, which is also
represented in her new
book, called "Rebel Talent."
And I am told that one of the
rebels she'll be talking about
is a fabulous Italian
chef, among others.
So we have lots of
good stuff in store.
So Francesca, come on up.
She's going to talk
for about 45 minutes--
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCESCA GINO: Thank you.
SPEAKER: --thank you--
45 minutes of content.
And save your questions.
If you're on the Livestream,
please feel free to ping them
to Al-Rahim Merali whose
LDAP is A-L-R-A-H-I-M.
And we will go from there.
FRANCESCA GINO: Perfect.
SPEAKER: Thank you so much.
FRANCESCA GINO: Welcome.
Thank you so much for
having me, and thank
you so much for all of you to
show up and come to the talk.
As you heard, we are
going to talk about some
of the ideas in the book.
And I want to share some
stories, a little bit
of the research
behind the scenes,
and hopefully
you're going to feel
as inspired as I felt when I was
working on this book project.
And I want to start with
a story that I heard
and I was told by, going
back to the restaurant,
by the person who works at
this three Michelin star
restaurant in Italy.
It's called Osteria Francescana.
They are in Modena.
And his name is
Giuseppe Palmieri.
And this is actually the
story of a family of four
who visited the restaurant
on a Friday night.
So imagine a father, a
mother, an eight-year-old boy,
and a 14-year-old boy.
And Palmieri helps
them find their table,
and then shows up
to take the order.
And the father,
incredibly happy,
makes an order for each
one of the four of them
for a tasting menu
that has 13 dishes
and is called Sensations.
And it's almost
lunchtime, so I want
to give you a sense
of the type of dishes
that are part of this menu.
So quite creative in the
way they're assembled.
That's eel.
Another dish that is part of
this 13 course tasting menu
is the one that you see here.
It looks like a funny ice
cream, but that's foie gras.
So not the type of dishes the
growing boys would hunger for.
Now, the father was so eager
to eat at the restaurant
that not only made the
reservations for Friday night,
he also made the reservations
for Saturday night.
So it's now 24 hours later.
The same family is
back at the restaurant.
And Palmieri again welcomes them
in, brings them to their table,
and then shows up
to take the order.
This time, again very
happily, the father goes
for a 10-course tasting
menu called the Tradition
in Evolution.
And again, I want to give you
a sense of the type of dishes
that are part of the menu.
One of them is called
snails under the earth.
It's served as a soup,
but there actually
is snails at the
bottom of the plate.
And they're hidden under a
foam of raw garlic and potato.
And the earth part of the
dish stands for black truffle,
coffee, and nuts.
Now, when Palmieri
was taking the order,
he noticed that the boys almost
had a face of desperation,
as if they were not
sharing the eagerness
and excitement of their father
to have another gourmet meal.
And the boys were keeping
quiet, but Palmieri
turned to the
eight-year-old at the table
and said, what would
you like to have?
Pizza, said the
eight-year-old boy.
Now, Osteria Francescana
is no pizzeria.
There is no way you could
find pizza on their menu.
And it's a rather serious place.
Fresh flowers are brought
into the restaurant every day.
The tables are put together
with surgical precision.
The dishes are arranged with
a lot of attention to detail.
And this is a restaurant that,
back in 2016, became the best
restaurant in the world.
And in fact, also
this year, in 2018,
they were back at
the top of the list.
But despite all of that,
when Palmieri heard pizza,
he excused himself,
ran to the phone,
called up the best pizzeria in
Modena, and ordered the pizza.
And sure enough, about 15,
20 minutes later, a pizza
showed up at the door
in a taxi, and pizza
was served to the boys.
Now, I'm telling you
this story because it's
a perfect example of what
rebel talent is all about.
Even in situations where
there are lots of rules,
as in the case of
fancy restaurant,
Palmieri was able to
keep his mind open,
look at the problem from
a different perspective,
and come up with a
rather creative solution.
So what I want to suggest
is that we all probably want
to be people like Palmieri.
If we think about our
leadership, broadly defined,
the people that we influence in
our different spheres of life,
whether at work or
in our personal life,
I would say that we
want to have people
who would order the
pizza like Palmieri
did in that particular instance.
Now, what's interesting is
that I would call Palmieri
a rebel for this behavior, for
many other behaviors that he
engages in on a regular
basis in his work,
but rebels usually
have a bad reputation.
I spend a lot of time
in organizations,
and I've collected all
sorts of words for them.
They're called the show offs.
Sometimes they're called the
jerks, or the annoying people
who slow you down in your
decision-making processes.
The troublemakers, the outcasts.
In fact, I think that we
often have a very precise idea
of the rebels in the business.
We think about people like
Apple visionary Steve Jobs.
So people who are incredibly
innovative and creative, but--
at least the stories
go-- not the type
of people you want to work
with, or have as a boss
or as an employee.
And what I want to do in the
time that we have together,
and it was a big motivation
for writing this book,
is try to shift that
thinking, and suggest
that people who I call rebels
are not people who break rules
just for the sake
of breaking rules,
they are not people
who are arrogant,
they are people who break rules
who hold them and others back.
And they break
rules in a way that
is very constructive
and productive
and positive for
their organizations.
So with that said, let me
share a few stories that
are going to allow
us to talk about what
are the ingredients
of their success.
And the first story
that I want to share
comes from the domain of sport.
Now, some of you
might know this guy
is a rather well-known coach.
His name is Maurice Cheeks.
And I want to tell you in
particular about the evening
of April 23, 2003.
This was a big night for him.
It was game three of the
first round of the 2003 NBA
championships.
And I'd like you to
imagine being there.
You're in a very big arena.
20,000 fans ready
to watch the game.
You're there with them, ready to
cheer up your team to success.
Millions of viewers from home.
And before the game
started, a girl
who is about 14
years in age stepped
into the arena ready to
sing the national anthem.
And what I'd like you to
do is watch a video clip
that I brought with
me of that moment.
And I'd like you
to pay attention
to what this coach does.
Why don't we do the following?
We'll come back to that.
And I'm going to talk about
a different ingredient first,
where we don't need to look
at the video quite yet.
The second ingredient
that seems to be something
the rebels do quite well
is having a great desire
for challenge and for novelty.
And I wanted to introduce
this ingredient by telling you
about a personal story.
It is Christmas time a few
years back at our house.
And this is not
what happened there.
I had what I thought was the
perfect gift for my husband.
And the only thing that
you need to know about him
is that he's the type
of person who would
be super-happy to work here.
So he's a complete geek.
So always loves the new piece of
technology, the latest gadget.
Everything that is
interesting and playful
when it comes to technology
is the perfect gift for him.
And so on Christmas
day, he runs downstairs.
There is a big tree
in the living room.
And under the tree,
he finds a big box
that I prepared for him.
And he takes the top off.
And then he starts taking some
pieces of paper out of the box.
There was this card at the
bottom of the box letting
you know that they signed us up
for a 10-week, two-hour a week
course in improv comedy.
Now as it turns
out, improv comedy
taught me all sorts of
interesting things that
are really good lessons for
life in thinking about the work
that we do and thinking about
the relationships that we have.
And in the spirit of
bringing to bear something
that I've learned by
taking this class,
I thought that we could
do an exercise together
that is one of the
exercise that we did quite
a few times throughout improv.
Now just to close
the story, my husband
wasn't too happy when I
signed him up for this class.
He really wanted the
latest gadget in his hands.
But I thought he was wrong.
And by the end of the
first two-hour class,
he actually told me
that he hated it.
But things started
to change as we
went on and on for
our weekly classes.
And he started really
enjoying having this date
with the unexpected.
So I'm going to ask each
of you, if you don't mind,
to stand up for this exercise.
I'm going to ask each of
you to find a partner.
So a person who is
standing close to you
that would work well.
Perfect.
And I'm going to put
myself up here so that you
can see the directions.
So this is not too difficult.
OK I'm going to ask you to
stand about this distance
from your partner.
There is somebody over
here who needs a partner.
Since you're working in pairs.
And if you don't have a partner,
you can also work with me.
I'm fine with that.
OK.
So here's what I'm
going to ask you to do.
From that position, you're
going to be standing
in front of your partner.
I'm going to ask you to
spend the next 20 seconds--
and I'm going to keep
the time for you--
staring in the eyes
of your partner.
OK?
And there are a few more
rules before you get started.
No laughing.
No talking.
No anything.
No really expression of
any emotions on your face.
OK?
So that's the exercise.
As I said, I'm going to
keep the time for you.
And when there is
silence, you can start.
And time.
How did that feel?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: It was great.
FRANCESCA GINO: It was great?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Your face is like, meh.
OK, for some of you,
maybe slightly awkward.
A little bit weird,
uncomfortable.
As it turns out, if you felt a
little bit awkward or slightly
uncomfortable, that's OK.
It means that you're human.
Because our brain knows
that if we stand that close
to a person looking in their
eyes for that amount of time,
one or two things
usually happen.
One, we're going
to kiss the person.
Two, we're going to
punch them in the face.
And I don't want any of
that to happen at Google.
So you can go to your partner,
shake their hands and say,
I'm not going to punch you.
I'm not going to kiss you.
OK, now that that
is out of the way--
no, no, no, stand up.
Not sitting yet.
There is the second
part to the exercise.
Now a beautiful
principle of improv
is the idea of always working
on scenes with a partner
and shifting the
attention from us to them.
Our goal in scenes is
always trying our best
to make our partner feel
good about what they're
doing, or feeling as
confident as they can
feel about what they're doing.
And again, what a beautiful
lesson about life more
generally.
And so to practice that,
we are going to go back
to the same position.
Again, I'm going to ask you to
engage in this 20-second period
of staring.
But this time, you're also
trying to pay attention.
So what is their eye color?
Is their haircut
an interesting one?
Or are there ears shaped in
a slightly different way?
Whatever you want to do.
You're trying to stare
but pay attention
to what they're doing.
OK?
Same rules as before.
So not talking, no laughing, no
facial expression of any kind.
OK?
Perfect.
If you're ready, let's go.
And time.
OK.
We're going to test whether you
were paying attention or not.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
FRANCESCA GINO: Seems
like that you were.
I know, oh.
That sounds like a
comment from my husband
as we were going
through classes.
You're going to turn
around 180 degrees.
So each one of you.
So this time it's not your
face looking at their face,
but it's your back
looking at their back.
Perfect.
And what I'm going to ask you
to do is, each one of you,
to think about two big changes.
So I don't know.
If you have glasses, you might
want to take your glasses off.
Or rough up your hair.
Be as creative as
you want to be.
And then make those two
changes on yourself.
OK?
No taking off clothes.
[LAUGHTER]
Just-- perfect.
OK.
If you have your two
changes, when you're ready,
you can turn around.
And each of you can
guess the changes
that you see in your partner.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRANCESCA GINO: OK.
Were you able to
figure them out?
Yeah?
Again, it's quite nice
to be able to shift
the attention from ourselves
to the other partner.
So hopefully, most of you
were able to see the changes
the other person actually made.
Now I'm going to do a final
part of this exercise.
And do we have music?
Are we good with audio?
Yeah?
Perfect.
OK.
We're going to do the
final part of the exercise.
And this is what I'm
going to ask you to do,
if you don't mind.
Do you like to dance?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
FRANCESCA GINO: Yes.
Oh, if I were to find
you on a dance floor,
what would you be doing?
AUDIENCE: Dancing.
FRANCESCA GINO: Can you
show me one of your moves?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I generally have, like--
and like--
FRANCESCA GINO: OK.
This is what I am seeing.
So something along-- sorry.
It's much better
than what I'm doing.
But it's something around that.
OK.
So your role as-- and
again, each of you
is going to do this in the pair.
Each of you is going to think
about their favorite dance
move.
And I'm going to
put on some music
and ask you to actually try it
out in front of your partner.
And then you are going to
switch when I say switch.
But here's the very important
role of the partner.
Since your task is to make your
partner feel as good as they
can feel about their dancing--
in this case, or as
confident as they
can feel about their dancing--
you're mirroring,
but exaggerating.
OK?
So whatever it is.
I don't know what I
would do this here.
But in a way, that really makes
them feel good about the way
they're dancing.
OK?
As I said, I'm going to put up
some music since it's easier
to dance that way.
You can decide who's
going to go first.
And when you're ready, the
first person can start.
[MUSIC - CARLY RAE JEPSON, "CALL
ME MAYBE"]
And shift.
OK.
So, applause to all of you.
You can take a seat.
Some really exceptional dancing
in this room, I have to say.
I'm very impressed.
How did that feel compared
to the first exercise when
you were staring?
The first time you did that.
AUDIENCE: Much better.
FRANCESCA GINO:
Much better, right?
It's interesting that
once we put ourselves
out there in situations where
we feel challenged where we're
always doing something
new, it becomes easier
to feel comfortable
with the uncomfortable.
That's what rebels often do.
Now I was obviously
very interested
in studying this idea in
the case of businesses.
And so I went to
businesses to try
to see how is it
that they injected
this idea of challenge
and novelty in the work
that people do.
And one of the
businesses I visited,
where I expected not to
find any rebelliousness,
is a fast-food chain in the
middle of Tennessee and West
Virginia.
They looked like this.
They are drive-through big
blue boxes with French fries
and hot dogs on their roof.
But they're quite
successful at what they do.
In fact, if you look at
any measure of performance,
revenue per square--
you name it, they beat
the competition by far.
And we're talking about big
brands like McDonald's, Burger
King, Wendy's.
Now they also invest in
people quite differently.
So if at a place like
McDonald's you receive an hour
and a half, two hours of
training per stations,
at Pal's, they give you 135
hours of training per station.
So they're really all about
making you an expert such
that you have the free
space in your mind
to think about how to improve
on the work that you do.
Now when I was there, I was
in the middle of the store
actually at rush hour.
And so you see people
working at their stations
almost like machines.
And I started thinking
that maybe work becomes
monotonous or even boring.
And yet, the general managers
have thought about this.
And so it's more ways
that they inject novelty.
One way in which they do this
is the idea of letting people
know the order
that they're going
to follow throughout the day--
the stations that
they're moving from, to--
when they show up for work.
So they create a little
bit of unpredictability,
a little bit of
novelty that allows
them to stay on their feet.
And what's also
interesting is that they
have all sorts of challenges
for the people working
in the stores.
My favorite to
date is a challenge
for the person working
at the windows.
So the person who
takes the order.
An interesting statistic
about Pal's is that they
have a lot of repeat customers.
So people who eat there
five to six times a week.
And they have a simple menu.
And so people who are
creatures of habit
tend to make the same order
whenever they show up.
And so the challenge for
the person at the window
was, if you can remember
100 orders in a row,
then there is this reward.
And it was really interesting
to see how the person really
experienced it as being pushed
in the work that she did.
And she was very happy
when she actually completed
the challenge successfully.
So what is very
true about rebels
is that they have this
desire for novelty.
They're not afraid of putting
themselves in situations
that makes them uncomfortable.
Now let's go back to the first
ingredient with the video
that I wanted to
show you earlier.
So you know the setup.
And as I said, the
idea is for you
to think about how
you'd feel if you were
in the shoes of this coach.
We're going to watch the video.
Maybe, maybe not, who knows?
A little bit of novelty.
And see what he does.
Pay attention to his behavior.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- And now to honor America
and salute the men and women
serving our country with
our national anthem,
please welcome as
voted by you, the fans
our winner of the Toyota
Get the Feeling of a Star
promotion, Natalie Gilbert.
[APPLAUSE]
[NATALIE GILBERT SINGING "THE
STAR SPANGLED BANNER"]
[APPLAUSE]
- [INAUDIBLE].
Come on, come on.
Starlight's last gleaming.
- Star's light--
- Last gleaming.
- Whose broad stripes--
[?
[NATALIE GILBERT SINGING "THE
STAR SPANGLED BANNER"] ?]
[APPLAUSE]
[END PLAYBACK]
FRANCESCA GINO: Now let
me ask you a question.
Does this guy have a good voice?
Absolutely not.
And yet it took
him no time to step
in the middle of the
arena and start singing,
helping the girl
who needed help.
What is impressive about him is
that he has no problem making
himself vulnerable even when
that means showing everybody
that clearly singing is
not one of his strengths.
But rather it's a weakness.
And that's what rebels seem
to be doing quite naturally.
They make themselves
vulnerable in a way that
is not backfiring, as
we often think it will.
But rather it buys
them a lot of respect.
In fact, if you didn't feel
moved in a little way at least
watching that, I think
you have no heart.
Because it really creates
an emotional connection
by doing what he does.
So as I said, rebels
are people who
seems to be quite happy
to jump in and to help.
Now they also are
people, as I said,
that they have this
interesting desire for novelty.
But I want to share a couple
of more of their ingredients.
And again, I'm going to go
back to the domain of sports.
And we're not going to
look at this guy playing,
we're going to see a
little boy, a younger boy,
getting into the baseball field.
And I'd like you to pay
attention to the reframing
that he does quite naturally.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I'm the greatest
hitter in the world!
Strike one.
I'm the greatest
hitter in the world!
Strike two.
Hmm.
I'm the greatest
hitter in the world!
[LOUD WHOOSHING]
Strike three.
[MUSIC - KOOL & THE
GANG, "CELEBRATION"]
Wow.
I'm the greatest
catcher in the world.
Yes!
- Optimism, pass it on.
[END PLAYBACK]
FRANCESCA GINO: Now this
little guy is very impressive.
We all tend to dwell
on our weaknesses.
We often over-invest
in our weaknesses.
And instead, he shifts his
attention to his strength.
And as it turns out,
that's what rebels do.
They play to their strengths
on a regular basis.
And that's something that makes
them feel authentic in the work
that they do.
Now I was very curious about
this idea of authenticity.
There is a lot of talking
in the world about the power
of authenticity.
And I was interested in looking
at whether a lot of the things
that we say about
authenticity are true
and so with my colleagues, we
went to all sorts of contexts
to look at whether authenticity
is in fact a powerful driver
in the work that we do.
So one of the contexts
that we explored
is entrepreneurial competitions.
So imagine entrepreneurs
showing up,
pitching their ideas
to venture capitalists.
And what we found is
that when entrepreneurs
are authentic and genuine
in their pitching,
they are three times more likely
to get money for their ideas.
Now authenticity is
also an interesting part
of the story of the chef
and owner of the restaurant
that I mentioned earlier,
Osteria Francescana.
You can see him here.
His name is Massimo Bottura.
A really interesting
person and leader.
In fact, it is a person
who went to a context
of traditional Italian
dishes and reinvented them.
Now I don't know how much
you know about Italians,
but there are two things
that are very true.
One is that there are lots of
rules when it comes to cooking.
And we cherish our old ways.
And he went to a
context where there
are lots of traditions
where recipes
have been passed on for
centuries, from generation
to generation.
And he basically
messed up the tradition
and came up with something new.
So he studied traditions
very carefully
and then started
asking questions.
Well maybe it made sense
cooking this dish this way
20 years ago, but not today.
Let's do something different.
So if you have ever
had lasagna, this
is his version of the lasagna.
It's called the crunchy
part of the lasagna.
It looks nothing like the
type of dishes I grew up with.
Now what is interesting is that
when he opened the restaurant,
traditional Italians
weren't too happy.
In fact, he talks about it as
actively fighting against him.
And when I asked him what
allowed him to stay persistent,
he told me about the
power of authenticity.
And in fact, he told me
about the story of the summer
that he spent at Eboli, at the
time, quite a famous restaurant
in Spain.
And what he learned
from the chef there.
And it was really a message
of feeling the freedom
and expressing the freedom
of playing to your strengths
and staying authentic.
And so this is the quote.
He said, "What changed me
was the message of freedom
that Ferran gave me, the
freedom to feel my own fire,
to look inside myself and
make my thoughts edible."
And sure enough, after the
summer, he back to Modena.
He sold everything that he had.
He borrowed money from
his wife's family.
And then he invested
the money and the time
in the restaurants.
He came up with new recipes.
And a few months later,
the first Michelin star
arrived, and the second
one, and the third.
And as I told you in
2016, the restaurant
became the best
restaurant in the world--
a moment of Italian
pride, since it
was the first time when an
Italian restaurant reached
the top of the list.
Now again, his story
is interesting.
But as a scientist,
I was curious to know
whether this story is more
generalizable-- the idea
of authenticity is
really powerful to help
us persist through challenges.
So one of the studies that
we conducted to look at this
is by bringing Red Sox
fans into HBS campus.
And what we did, we gave
them one or two types
of wristbands to wear--
either the wristband of their
favorite team, the Red Sox,
or the wristband of
the New York Yankees.
And then we put them through all
sorts of challenges in the hour
that we had with them.
And at the very end,
one of the challenges
was to ask them to put
their dominant hand
in a bucket of ice.
And so we were paying
them the longer
they kept their hand
in a bucket of ice.
We were interested
in seeing whether you
see more persistence when people
experience authenticity, even
in the case of tolerance to
pain and physical persistence.
And sure enough, across all
the different challenges
we put them through, people
who felt authentic just
for wearing the wristband
of their favorite team
were much more likely to
persist through challenges,
even when it came to keeping
their hands in the bucket
of ice at the end of the study,
suggesting that authenticity
is really quite
powerful in helping
us resist through challenges.
Now what this tells us, and
the reason why I'm telling you
this story is that
they are quite
interesting in showing
one of the talents
the rebels seem to have.
They are people who play to
their strength quite often.
But they also help
others do the same.
A few years back, I
came across a quote
of an Italian sculptor
and artist that
really stayed with me.
You probably know
some of his work.
His name is
Michelangelo Buonarroti.
Here's what he wrote about
the sculpting process.
He said, "Sculpting is a process
whereby the artist releases
an ideal figure from the block
of stone in which it slumbers."
To me, that's very
powerful because it
raises the question of, what
if we were to look around
in our professional lives, at
work, or in our personal lives,
and started with the assumptions
that fundamentally, everybody
has talent, and that our role--
as colleagues, as leaders,
as parents, as friends--
is to help them bring those out.
So I bought into
this idea and then
I started asking questions of
how do we do that concretely?
And so I'm going to leave
you with a couple of examples
that maybe might
trigger some suggestions
or ideas in your head.
The first story comes
from Ariel Investments.
This is a Chicago-based
money management firm.
And the president
of Ariel Investments
is the woman that you
see in the picture.
Her name is Mellody Hobson.
Remarkable woman,
really successful.
Really interesting what she does
to bring a lot of this talent
into her organization.
And when I asked her to
tell me a little bit more
about her career,
she told me that she
started working at
Ariel at the age of 22,
right after graduating
from college.
No working experience.
And she's been quite successful.
So what was the
secret to her success?
She referred to the advice
that she received directly
from the CEO at the time
on the first day of work.
And this is what
the CEO told her.
"You are going to be
in rooms with people
who have a lot of money
and have big titles.
But it doesn't mean
that your ideas are not
as good or even better.
I want to hear your ideas.
It is incumbent on
you to speak up."
So from the very
first day, she had
the license of bringing
her contributions forward.
And this is advice that
she shares with everybody
at the firm, or everybody
that she brings into the firm.
Now back in 2011, I
had an opportunity
to think about how
to apply these ideas.
I was working with a company
called Wipro Technology.
They are based in India.
And in particular,
my colleagues and I
were working with
their business process
outsourcing side
of the business.
So imagine people
working in call centers.
Now as you might imagine,
it's a tough job.
And in fact, what
Wipro was experiencing
was investing a lot in people,
bringing them in, and then
45 to 60 days into
the job, most people
were leaving the organization.
So not the greatest investment.
And so we did an
intervention with them
where we gave people who joined
a half hour of reflection.
We asked them to think
about their strengths,
to think about what's
unique about them,
and how they could play to their
strengths more often at work.
And since we wanted to test
the ideas, some of the people
actually went through this
revised welcoming process.
Some of them went through
the regular welcoming process
at Wipro.
And then we looked
at turnover rates
seven months after
the intervention.
And what we found is that
moments of reflection
where people had the
chance to think about what
makes them authentic--
and how they could bring
that out into work--
was quite powerful.
So people were more likely
to be with the organization
seven months later.
They were also much
happier in their jobs.
And they performed better,
as we know from the ratings
on customers' calls.
And what is
interesting, I think,
about this study is that it's in
a context where the job is very
scripted, suggesting
that even there, there
is an opportunity for us
to rely on this talent.
So what these different
studies and stories
tell us is that rebels
play to their strengths
on a regular basis, but they
also help others do the same.
And again, I felt very
inspired by learning
about this in a way
that made me think about
work a little bit differently.
So let me share a
final ingredient
and then we're going to
open it up for questions.
This is I think, at the moment,
one that really puzzles me.
And it's a talent for curiosity.
And it puzzles me because
we're all born with it.
In fact, if you
look at the data,
curiosity peaks at the
age of four and five.
And then it declines
steadily from there.
I think that that's a
sad finding and a missed
opportunity.
And I don't know if
you can still remember
the time you were a kid.
It's way too long ago for me.
So I think about my children who
are at the age where curiosity
is really coming out.
And it's constant questioning.
Just before I left for this
trip they were asking questions
about, why is the sky blue?
Or why is it that we
need to wear clothes
when we leave the house?
It's constant exploring
and a sense of wonder
and questioning.
We seem to be losing that.
And in fact, when
I looked at this
in the context of
organizations, I
looked at people
who were starting
new jobs across a different
set of industries.
And it seems like curiosity
is pretty high, as you start.
But when you go back
to the same people
six to eight months
later, curiosity
had dropped across the
board by at least 20%.
It doesn't have to be that way.
And in fact, rebels are people
who keep their curiosity alive
and also encourage it in others.
So I'll give you a
couple of examples.
One comes from Intuit.
Every year they have
innovation awards.
And these are for
people who have
random explorations that led to
new products or new processes.
But they also have
failure awards.
And these go to people
whose explorations did not
end up in a new product, but led
to good learnings for the team.
And what's most exciting
about this example
is that the failure awards
come with a failure party.
So you're really
creating an atmosphere
where exploration is, in
fact, supported and valued.
Now we started with a
story about the restaurant,
Osteria Francescana.
So we are going to end with a
story about this restaurant.
This is a very busy night
at Osteria Francescana.
And one of their sous chefs that
is known internally as Taka,
was working on the last
dessert of the night.
And it was a lemon tart.
Taka is known for being obsessed
with precision and attention
to detail.
And so he was working
very carefully
arranging the different
pieces on the plate.
And all of a sudden, the
plate dropped to the floor.
And now he had a
smashed lemon tart.
Now Taka was starting to
panic, trying to understand
and figure out what to do.
And as he was feeling this
way, chef Massimo Bottura
walked into the kitchen and
saw the plate on the floor.
And rather than yelling,
as I bet a lot of leaders
would do in fancy restaurants,
he looked at the plate
and said, I think we have
a new item for our menu.
And sure enough, they came
up with a new dessert.
It's now one of their
most popular desserts
at the restaurant.
And it looks like this.
I took a picture
when I was there.
It's smashed on the plate even
in the way that it's prepared.
And the name for it is Oops,
I Dropped the Lemon Tart.
And it's just a
great example of how
curious people, or
curious leaders like him,
are able to even look
at accidents or mistakes
and turn them into a
source of inspiration.
So it seems as if
these rebels do
have a recipe to their success.
And if you look at how
they use their talents,
there are all sorts of
behaviors that they engage in
on a regular basis.
And there are many of them
I write about in the book.
I just captured a few
of them on these slides.
And it's not for
talking through them.
But just to give you the idea
that a lot of these things,
a lot of these
behaviors, are not
requiring a complete
restructuring
of the organization or
rethinking over what
we're doing, but they
require some thoughtfulness
on our part.
Now these rebels share
five talents, no matter
what industry or job they do.
And we talked about some
of them in more detail.
They have this talent
for authenticity.
They have a talent for novelty.
Rather than going with the
familiar and comfortable
they challenge themselves.
There have a talent
for curiosity.
They have a talent
for perspective,
a little bit like what Palmieri
did when looking at the problem
rather than being stuck
on the obvious answer.
He looked at it from
multiple perspectives.
And finally, they have
a talent for diversity.
So they are people who really
do reject social rules that
are passed on to us by society.
And they think about
surrounding themselves
with people who think
differently and can challenge
their way of thinking.
And they really
leverage differences.
So let me stop here.
I have many more
stories to tell you.
But I'm kind of
curious to see what
questions are on your mind.
SPEAKER: Before
we get into that,
let me just remind you, if
you're on the Livestream,
feel free to ping
Al-Rahim Merali.
So he's A-L-R-A-H-I-M@.
We can start with the room.
AUDIENCE: Francesca,
thanks for that.
Oh, thanks for that great talk.
I'm just curious, so the
literature on creativity
shows that people
are most creative
under some level of constraint?
Total freedom is not great
for the creative process.
Similarly, do rebels
depend on there
being some shared assumptions
for them to question
and break, to some extent?
And does that mean
not everyone can
be a rebel in an
organization, right?
There has to be some
kind of shared culture
or structure or something like
that for them to operate best.
FRANCESCA GINO: Mm-hmm.
So in one of the
chapters in the book that
comes a little bit later,
I talk about the principles
that rebels live by.
And it was something that was
inspired by going potentially
to a strange place.
So one of the organizations
that I studied
as I was working on this
book was pirate ships
in the 16th century.
They're fascinating.
And I had all sorts of
wrong ideas about them.
And the ships, the
crews actually,
had principles that everybody
agreed upon before they
left for their journeys.
And similarly, rebels
have principles.
One of them is finding
freedom in constraint.
So you're right in saying
that the fact that there
our structures, norms, rules
allows them to bring out
some of their creativity.
Now to your question
of does that
mean that affects
the number of rebels
that we have in
the organization?
I usually receive the
question in the form of,
what's the exact
percentage of rebels
that I should have
in the organization?
And my answer is
always the same.
It makes people
feel uncomfortable.
It's 100%.
And the reason is that, if
you look at these talents,
there is nothing threatening
about them other than requiring
a little bit more openness to
people that bring into work
different perspectives.
And one of the things
that is true about rebels
is that, you get to
be more innovative,
to perform better in your job,
to have better relationships
at work because you're
fully engaged in the work
that you do.
And so I've been struck by the
data that is very well known
about engagement across
the globe and the fact
that there are 2/3 of
workplaces full of people
who are disengaged, or
actively disengaged.
It's just puzzling and strange.
And I met some of those people
and really the experience
is, the work sucks
for many of them.
And so I think that
encouraging rebelliousness,
you also get the engagement that
leads to all sorts of benefits.
So 100%.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
rebels play to their strengths.
And so I wanted to ask a
question related to growth
mindset and fixed mindset.
So if they're playing
to their strengths,
does that mean that they're
not improving or building
on their weaknesses?
I'm wondering if you
think that it's not
useful to do that and just
focus on building more strength?
FRANCESCA GINO: Yeah.
So I actually think that if
you look at the two talents
that I talked about,
capture this idea
of learning and growing.
So novelty means putting
yourselves out there
in situations that
challenges in a way
that allows you to
develop new skills.
And so that's the part
of the growth mindset.
But there is also
this idea that you
focus a lot of what you do
on what gives you energy.
That is what I mean by
playing to your strengths.
It's the way that makes
you feel authentic.
So I don't see the
two in contradictions.
It seems like rebels
do both quite well.
And one of the things
that, across the board--
I don't use that the label
growth mindset as much.
But I use thirst for learning,
which in a sense, it's similar.
And this willingness
to grow in their job
is quite important for rebels.
In fact, some people say,
what about arrogance?
Arrogance is not part of their
playbook, but humility is.
I'll give you a quick
story, if you don't mind.
And it's in one of the chapters
where I talk about perspective.
The person I mention there
that really surprised me is,
a captain that you
probably all know
is Captain Sully Sullenberger.
This is the captain
who ditched the plane
with 155 passengers
in the Hudson River
back on a cold evening of 2009.
And when I found myself
reading the accident report,
I was amazed by what he did.
He had 208 seconds
to make decisions.
That's the time that he had
when he discovered that there
was no thrust in the
engines and the time
in which the plane
in the Hudson River.
Most of us under such
time pressure and stress
would narrow our
thinking and options.
He instead was broadening
his perspective.
He kept considering what it
is that we could be doing.
And I reached out
to him, since I
was curious about his approach.
And what I've learned is that
by the time of the accident
happened, he had a
ton of experience--
over 30,000 hours of
flying under his belt.
He had served in
the military, so he
had all sorts of experience
flying all sorts of planes.
He had served as a volunteer
in previous accidents,
so he knew a lot about
what can go wrong.
But every time he
walked into the cockpit,
he would ask himself
what it is that could
be different in this case,
what it is that he could learn.
And so he kept that
intellectual [INAUDIBLE]
that I've seen a
lot of rebels that
allows them to keep looking at
their experience as a signal
not that they know it all,
but that there is more
to grow and learn.
AUDIENCE: We have a question
from the Livestream.
Most of the examples you've
shared involve men as rebels.
How do you think that
rebellious behavior
is treated when those
rebels are outside
of the gender or
ethnic majority?
FRANCESCA GINO: Very good point.
And I tried in the
book to actually
be much broader in the sense
of not only going outside
of the United States,
but also having
both examples of men and women,
as well as different groups.
Now I collected
some data on this,
since one of the questions
that I always receive is,
can women or minorities break
rules as much as white men?
And the answer is that
we perceive they can't.
But actually the
benefits of embracing
these talents are
equal for men and women
and for all sorts of
groups, which I think
is quite refreshing.
For gender more specifically,
after the book came out,
I ended up writing
a blog post for HBR
where I talks specifically--
drawing on a chapter on the
book-- on gender issues.
And sort of giving tips out
of the book of why is it
and how is it that
women can break rules.
Well yes, so we
have the perception,
but it is the wrong perception.
And we can all
break rules equally.
SPEAKER: I think we
have time for one more--
FRANCESCA GINO:
Within the legal line.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
I'm curious about the
downsides of being a rebel.
So all the examples you
give are about the upsides
and the rewards.
But obviously, there's
a lot of inherent risk
as you make yourself more known,
take bigger risks and more
decisions.
So what research have
you done in that area?
FRANCESCA GINO:
So part of it is,
the fact that you're pushing
for something different.
And so I think the
case of Bottura
is a great example
where you might
have to fight some resistance
before getting accepted.
But in terms of, when is it
that they could really go wrong,
or when the costs
are really high,
I think that for that
it happens for rebels
that are not effective.
And what I mean by
this is that often,
especially in
organizations where
you feel that maybe the
top leadership is not
supporting this approach,
people get frustrated.
And that frustration often
turns into the wrong delivery
as you're trying to
use these talents.
I'm going to give you
a concrete example.
So after the book came
out, a student of mine
wrote me in a message
and said, I saw the book.
I bought the book.
I read the book.
I think that you need
to change your subtitle.
I was like, OK, it says,
why it pays to break
the rules at work and in life.
And we are scientists.
So I obviously always want to
learn and I might be wrong.
So I called him up and we had
a conversation for two hours.
And basically his argument
was, I'm the perfect rebel,
based on your descriptions,
but things are not
working out for me.
And from what he was saying, I
couldn't quite figure it out.
And as it turns out, his job
is right outside of Boston.
So I said, why don't
I come for three days
and follow you at work,
like a neutral observer
in the background.
I thought it would be a
great experience for me just
to learn about his approach.
And after the first half a
day, I was like, OK, I get it.
And it was the delivery
that was wrong.
I think he was really frustrated
by what the top leadership was
encouraging.
And so he was using
a lot of arrogance.
So for example, in a meeting--
this was just priceless.
The group was talking
about a decision
that the company
was considering.
And everybody who talked before
him was agreeing on the fact
that it was the right approach
of looking at this decision.
And he was raising his hand.
He was super-angry.
And then when he got
called on, he said,
I understand what
you all said and why
you might think that way, but
it is actually the wrong way
of approaching the decision.
In fact, I cannot even think
of an even more wrong way
of looking at the decision.
What I suggest we do
instead-- and then
he blurted out his answer.
And I was just in between crying
and laughing in seeing that,
because the approach was wrong.
So I think that
that's often when
things get a little bit
difficult for people
and they encounter costs.
SPEAKER: Great, thank you.
I'm sure we have a
lot more questions.
But unfortunately
we are out of time.
So--
FRANCESCA GINO: I'll
leave you with that.
So that if you have
extra questions
you should feel
free to reach out.
I'll also leave you with
the following thing.
Some of you might feel, maybe,
not at ease with the idea.
And so to get started on
this wonderful journey,
you might want to go
to the book website.
It's called rebeltalents.org.
And there is a little test that
tells you which type of rebel
you are.
So which type of talents come
more easily or less easily
to you.
And so you're going
to receive some tips.
And if you come out as a
pirate, it's a good thing.
It's actually quite
a very good thing.
So thank you so much.
MODERATOR: Thank you
so much for being here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]